[Music]
do you guys think people are hotter LA
or New York I think I think I don't know
it depends where you go like Soho in New
York I feel like every like 100% they're
literally going to modeling jobs yeah
it's [__] crazy it's crazy yeah I was
working in SoHo this past spring and
yeah my friend Stephanie kept being like
Oh my God another model another model
they're lit they're like working models
no I know yeah they are I mean that's
what's funny about those Tik toks where
people go up to them on the street it's
always in SoHo yeah and they're always
actual models right right hotter right
what I'm thinking who's I find people
hotter in New York I think something
about that
aesthetic I don't know I think like La
hot is just you
know you don't eat you're hella hung
over doing a lot of coke and you're
actually from [__] you're actually
from like Indianapolis or something you
know yeah yeah feel like La hot is just
like thin body
dysmorphia partying a lot yeah it's like
a rockar hot it's kind of New York too
though is it yeah there's just more
there's definitely more plastic surgery
in there yeah that you know what that's
what it is yeah yeah that's true inject
it up the fall is a great time to be in
New York oh it's incredible God you were
just there yeah was magical oh yeah love
that City anytime you go somewhere with
Seasons again you're like oh I know what
if I could just live somewhere where I
had Seasons I miss it so much yeah yeah
la oh man who cares about La we're so
unlucky in southern
california0 every day what where it's
70° every day yeah that's why people
crazy here that's why people go insane
here why cuz they have the perfect
weather every day yeah that's how you
lose touch yeah but I get it when people
like from the East Coast move here and
they're like I'm [__] never gone back
yeah I get it yeah I know I do think
there's something psychological with
like you want to go through like the
winter to go into like the winter of
your mind and then like Bloom and the
summer and stuff and in La when it's
always the same it's it's hard to have
that same Evolution you need the phases
yeah yeah yeah yeah you need time
passing yeah yeah yeah I do smells so
good fall and winter it's like it's so
magical you know someone in [__]
Missouri right now in [__] ass dog [__]
here and this going you all three of you
I hope you die soon yeah yeah yeah
they're listening to this and their
podcast has they're like scraping ice
off their [__] car like oh yeah yeah
yeah it's beautiful sh the [__] yeah
exactly they're driving a
snowplow up to Canada it's Jeremy
rener sorry sorryy I can't stay away he
made it though he did he he made it
through jar bear made it was was it a
snowflower or was it a
Zamboni for some reason is that a real
thing a Zamboni that's when somebody
handing College they're like you want a
zambon what don't they call or like you
want you want a hit of this weed no
that's a Xanax little
Zamboni Zamboni I thought ice was for a
Zen a Zen you know everyone comes up
with the names for zins you know what is
that like Zen Laden oh yeah it's a wait
what is a Zen a vape no it's a m oh
it's a nicotine pouch yeah Scandinavian
dip is it really yeah yeah it's a
Scandinavian brand no it's I thought it
was I thought it was like from the
Netherlands I think this company is
American but I think that it's based on
Snus based on Snus yeah but maybe I'm
wrong you guys ever been to Norway
Sweden oh yes you have on my worldwide
tour you did on your world I want to go
so bad I'm addicted to Barry's boot camp
and they have them in Sweden and Norway
that's why you want to go that's why I
want to go no no but I am someone if I'm
on vacation and I'm somewhere that has a
berries boot camp in the city you're
going it's like the perfect vacation cuz
then I'm having my workout every morning
I'm coming out Feeling High that's yeah
that's you the best way to vacation is
you do a [__] hard ass workout in the
morning and then you just drink all day
yeah and then you just party party party
in in Oslo Norway yeah Oslo was Beach
that I'm so surprised I got through it I
there was a show called Oslo yeah oh
yeah do you like Oslo oh slow down I'm
on a
bust thank you that's good that's good
he's on the board man he's is that from
We're referring to the movie Speed or
just in general I'll Slow
Down Speed they're on a bus they need to
slow down they can't that's what can
said they can't oh slow down the bus
yeah yeah no that show the that show was
really cool because my hotel room was
connected to the venue and I was jet
lagged so I'm like oh let me take a
little nap before the show I woke up 30
seconds before going on stage that was
that was a [__] fever dream Jed lag
is crazy yeah yeah yeah PE other people
are like well you just and I'm like this
is not this is not a small problem this
is like sucks I am awake at a time when
it should be the deepest sleep of my
life you know and I'm
like it takes your body an out a
one day day per hour to adjust per hour
of jet lag or of like time difference so
you have to be somewhere for a [__]
for more than eight days eight days
exactly to get used to anything I know
everybody says that and it's like do you
realize what you're saying got be here
go to Europe for vacation for a week you
don't I know when people do that I'm
like you mean you're taking a little jet
lag
vacation fing life on the other side of
the world for a week and then you a
vampire you hat your life for another
week there was there was a [__] there
was a mesh rope in front of the stage
because between the seats and the stage
there's like a like deeper than an
orchestra pit I don't know what it's for
yeah basically um and I just kept
imagining just getting narcoleptic in
the middle of the set just being
like that would be lit wait you guys
have seen that standup comedian woman
fainting right no booster blue shot and
I'm going to be honest I have the
shingle shot too
and I still get my period what yes
what's
sad traveled went to Mexico twice the
the fainting is s did shows meet and
greets I'm I'm really
nervous he should be Jesus loves me the
most seriously check it out so nice so
nice oh oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I
remember this oh yeah I remember this
it's a classic movie style Fame yeah
people think it's it's a joke cuz she's
talking about all these vaccines and she
faints it's so sad this was everybody I
already know got yeah all the comment
see everyone was taking seriously until
this moment then all the comments are
going to be like damn Noel you could
have helped her
faster
oh lift the legs dummy I mean she hit
her head pretty [__] hard let's see
it again why you slowing it down so much
inant replay that's what Luke did I
didn't okay let's let's
analyze yeah it was the mic that no her
head hits yeah it it hit but she kind of
hit her body first the low back broke
the fall a little bit she suffered a
fractured
skull and a concussion and still checks
in with doctors but has had no lingering
issues and still checks in with
doctors just checking in what's good yo
remember that [__] that was
crazy